okay thank you for watching so what I'm
hoping to show you is how I made a
fairly cheap inexpensive ball stop
barrier to you know keep lacrosse balls
from rolling in the street and down the
track and just kind of wanted to share
this with with you guys and you know
maybe you can find it something like
this useful so it's basically a PVC
frame with deer netting plastic
polyurethane deer netting as the barrier
so it's about ten feet wide and about
seven and a half feet tall because it's
made of PVC pipe it's very very
lightweight so this one's already been
made I kind of want to walk over here
and show you the supplies I have to kind
of make another one so this began as a
hundred foot long roll of deer net I've
actually made that ten foot one that I
just showed you and I also made one that
was 20 feet wide I can show you the pros
and cons of a 20 foot one later so what
I have is three pieces of ten foot long
PVC pipe one inch diameter and then I
have one piece of 10 foot long PVC pipe
half an inch diameter as far as the
fittings go it's all pretty it's pretty
simple I have a four-way one inch
diameter two of those fittings right
there and I have two elbows one inch
diameter but then the other end reduces
down to a half an inch diameter and I
have some zip ties hacksaw to cut down
the PVC pipe add some glue PVC pipe glue
and just pair of sharp pliers or
scissors something to cut the deer net
all right I'm gonna stop the video for a
moment make some progress on this and
then I'll pick up in a moment
okay let's see if I can give you an
update so I had three ten foot long one
inch diameter pieces of PVC you're not
being scientifically fancy here I just
kind of line the bottom of the PVC up
and laid it down on top of the deer and
the deer mash the deer net and just with
the hacksaw just kind of cut two of them
and there's one of the pieces so the
third piece is still untouched so I'm
just gonna move this third piece out of
the way
eventually I'll need it but I cut two
pieces of those PVC pipes and here you
can see what I did on the other end so
this is actually going to be the top of
the deer net I used one of the elbows
and added PVC glue and then I braided
the half-inch diameter PVC ten-foot long
half-inch diameter i braided every three
or four squares in and out in and out in
and out this will prevent the the wall
the net from sagging so every three or
four squares I just braided in and out
in and out in and out and there's the
end it's ten foot long so all I'm gonna
do now is the same thing I'll take my
other elbow that I have and I'll take my
glue and I'll put some glue on the
inside glue it on and eventually then
we'll take the other piece of one-inch
PVC that I cut and kind of snap
everything together again put some glue
in here put some of that blue PVC glue
in here so it snaps on I'm gonna pause
it make some progress
okay so you can see I've made a whole
lot of progress I've gone ahead and
zip-tied the deer net mesh every foot or
so to the PVC pipe you don't have to do
that along the top because you've
braided the top rail every three or four
squares and now here's where I left off
in the previous segment so I've gone
ahead and glued the elbow and added the
opposite rail and notice I've already
now cut the deer net and zip tied again
about every foot or so to the other PVC
pipe so if I stand back
use your imagination if this thing we're
standing straight up and it's not ready
yet but it'll be about seven and a half
feet tall and about ten feet wide so now
I got to put the bottom of the bone or
the bottom of the of the wall together
so I have my four way PVC fitting you
imagine this is gonna snap on I'll add
some glue of course and the last piece
of ten foot long one-inch diameter PVC
pipe will be at the bottom that way no
balls will slip underneath it now and
kind of defeat the purpose of building
the wall here so I'm gonna go ahead and
stop the video make some progress and
I'll pick up in just a few moments
okay so made some real progress and the
frame of the backstop is virtually done
you can see I simply glued the four-way
PVC and the one-inch diameter PVC pipe
together and in these holes will be the
legs so the wall will stand up and not
topple over and you can see I just
zip-tied all the way along the bottom
and I thought about braiding all the way
along the bottom like I did all the way
along
but this is one-inch diameter PVC and
along the top is o is half-inch diameter
so I thought the one-inch was a little
thick the one-inch PVC it'll fit through
the holes of defense and is didn't like
you know put a lot of stress and tension
on the fence and I thought of bvv bore
may be more likely to rip so I just have
tied it in a moment I'll clip off the
ends of the zip ties and remember when
we cut the 10-foot long one-inch
diameter PVC s so here are the leftover
pieces and which will conveniently
conveniently be two legs now I still
have to cut two more legs for the other
support but very easy to do and once I'm
done it should be standing up and ready
to show you the final product so I'll be
right back okay so I think I have a
finished product here so you know the
two pieces of PVC that we cut down I
just took those two scraps and inserted
one into each of the open ends of the
4-way connector and so that will support
this one leg or this one beam but then
the other side I did something different
I was kind of experimenting with this
the other day you know some of my kids
kind of have a hard time pulling out the
legs whenever we have to take them down
and put them in storage or just take
them down and put them in storage it
just leaning leaning them up against the
fence out of the way but some of them
have a hard time pulling out some of our
kids have a hard time pulling out the
PVC legs right there so what I did was I
bought a piece of 3/4 inch PVC and you
can see because it's 3/4 inch it just
slides right through the 1 inch diameter
and out the other end so I've been kind
of experimenting with this to see if
this will work as a good support and I
think it will just in this case I
probably cut
this piece a little too short maybe
another a few inches longer would have
been better but there you go I have a 10
foot barrier ball stopper to keep
lacrosse balls out of the street
obviously you can use it for however you
feel now one of the cons of this I've
discovered is I put it next to the goal
the La Crosse goal and you know if we
shot wide my thinking was the ball would
hit the barrier and we wouldn't have to
go chasing very far the problem is is we
have some pretty strong shooters on the
team and their shot kind of tore a hole
through the mesh here so probably not a
good idea if you're looking to build
this to put right directly behind the
goal to keep balls to keep your shots
closer to the goal but if you want to
use this to keep balls out of the
neighbor's yard in my case to keep balls
out of the street to keep balls from you
know rolling down the track and rolling
away you know it's pretty helpful the
beginning of the video I mentioned that
I made a 20 foot long piece as well and
here it is again when we take them apart
we just lean them up against the fence
so here is the 20 foot pawn notice the
legs are not attached currently because
we just pulled the legs off and lean it
up against the fence to store it but
here you have a 10 foot long section
with a five-way the 5 way middle support
PVC fitting and then another 10 foot
long section so 20 feet long total you
still have elbow with the 1 inch
diameter and then the half inch reducer
I still braided back and forth and then
in the middle I don't know what you call
this connector but a t-connector again
it's also a reducer this is a 1 inch
diameter and this is a 1/2 inch and a
half inch reduced diameter so I think
it's just called a t-connector and then
again
Bradon the half-inch PVC and there's the
other elbow and it works great once it's
up it it's light it's the but it still
kind of takes three people to carry it
one person holding each post because if
you put one person on the fire pole one
person on one end and another person on
the other end because it is PVC it'll
sag in the middle and it just kind of
wobbly it's not very stable to carry but
everything is glued together pieces
aren't gonna fall apart so maybe have
three people carry it just for ease of
carryin and then you snap on the legs
two legs on the left side two legs in
the middle and two legs on the right and
now this is a 20 foot long barrier so
yeah you know make them however long you
want just the longer they are the harder
they're gonna be to move so there's my
homemade ball stop that I use with my
lacrosse kids to you know keep balls out
of the streets and hopefully not at the
chase so much hope you found this
helpful
thanks for watching